welcome back everybody the season 2
episode 101 of the h3 we are joined here
by my lovely and beautifully pregnant
wife and co-host buick liners stand up
and shout it from the rooftop show it
off show it off huh more than half way
more than half way yeah shit's getting
real and of course we are joined by the
Alicia's bodacious Vsauce
one of my favorite people here on the
show a wonderful dude beautiful beard as
well it's getting big
do you use beard oils I need to start
it's getting a bit dry now after a
shower it's just really hard to eat
right yeah do you ever catch some crumbs
or flavors in your mouth and does that
disgust you or intrigue you when though
I love it but if others are around it's
embarrassing to do today is Jake ropers
birthday oh hey and we had a big cake
covered in frosting and I could not eat
it without the tips of my mustache and
covered in frosting little flavor savors
stick them right in your mouth mm-hmm
now do you ever have a piece of chicken
that's perhaps been in your beard for
too long and you're like well I did
enjoy that I wonder about this you know
what's the word help me out Michael
you're smart guy I don't know what
you're getting at except it's rotting is
the chicken rotting in your beard and
you eat it oh no no no it's just kind of
getting more flavor
oh it's airing out if it's getting the
sort of beard and the skin cell and all
that kind of mess fermenting yeah I
don't eat a lot of chicken though to be
totally honest I'm more saving crumbs
and liquid residues right okay well
those are safe and those will not spoil
as far as I'm aware so observe the beard
so I want also first of all thank you to
our sponsors ring honey and me aunties
and I want to say Michael thanks for
coming on here to promote your show
season 3 of mine feel the season 3 and
that is super exciting perhaps the
longest-running YouTube red show of all
time
and I want to say the most successful
and I don't care about stats or anything
too
combat that because I think and believe
that's true no one knows the stats yeah
like Netflix you know YouTube premium
they kind of keep it secret 'iv but so
all I have to go off is like people's
reaction well you heard it here it's the
most popular show by phone I'm gonna
quote you on that by far yeah yeah by
far so well first before we get into
that because there's a lot I want to ask
you about the new season but before we
get into that I want to ask you Michael
because you're a man of science maybe
you can explain to me what the hell is
this look on the screen yeah the Raiders
owner Mark Davis Deadpool and John
Denver so that I get it I see it so this
is Mark Davis he's the owner of the
Raiders yeah all team he's worth a court
he's worth half a billion dollars yeah
and this is his haircut he looks like
Tweedledee from Alice in Wonderland I
find it pretty cool you are if you're
worth that much money
mm-hmm look at the confidence you can
have right you know Marc Davis is not
thinking
oops he's thinking this isn't a mistake
this is the new trend right Martin's
gonna start doing this
Elon Musk well so that's so great I like
your analysis okay my computers but here
he is without that and I think it looks
like half birthday that's is that the
same person I believe so Marc Davis
looks the same Marc Davis is also a
pitcher wait but it looks like the same
dude I mean that's the same deal look at
his face right the fact is I think the
noses in his pointy hmm Dan confirmed
this but regardless this is factual this
is his girl right so he's really that
looks so similar there's probably just a
lot of Marc Davis's but you think that
there would be at least a little
variance in the way they look well he's
committed he would never cut this beauty
apparently he drives 400 miles from the
North Bay to Palm Springs to get this
haircut no kid he's just he has a barber
he loves it and he drives there every
time he needs a haircut and he rocks it
every time and look at that's awesome
cuz look if
he had yeah a normal haircut we would
not be talking about him right now
absolutely not and as we all know he is
going after the fame he's a clout he's
chasing that clout with this haircut but
anyway so I thought that would be an
interesting start Mark Davis shout out
to you and your wonderful I wonder if I
could do a bowl cut on my beard like an
upside down bowl cut put a bowl around
the beard and cut everything that's
sticking out and just have a bowl shaped
you would need it somehow to defy
gravity because yeah it go I have a like
layup but that would be fantastic I
would do it what could you if you ever
do a video about gravity on Vsauce that
could potentially be interesting it
could be I wish my hair was longer and
more flowing mmm I mean touch my beard
if you want its Bungie it's a dick yeah
where are you going with that is there a
goal my goal my goal is to I want to
look like shel silverstein it turns out
he never had a beard that was quite this
big really for real um I remember him as
a bearded - gentleman I know but it
wasn't like this I mean that's just
beautiful
that's formidable as it gets look come
on guys it's a great look you know and I
loved his work as a kid and I still do
now now here's the other thing I want to
do I'm gonna go full moustache and
goatee so you guys kind of look like I'm
gonna cut everything here back I have
some big sideburns and there's a huge
goatee buy a bike I don't know if I
approve exactly I'm pulling the Mark
Davis you're going people Mark David do
something everyone goes why and then
like the other half the population goes
I guess I have to look like that
tune what would be the most extreme
thing you could do with your facial hair
now because I see with like a with like
a soul patch yeah and a mustache only
but that's not enough I think your idea
is much more extreme yeah my identity is
free while yeah with because that's not
an end right now either
no yeah that is how you set trends you
do things that are terrible first what
does your wife think about that oh she
hates it yeah but I keep telling her
look everyone who hates it will just go
oh it must be a joke
but those who like it will be like I
like it right so it's a win-win yeah
nobody judges you and I'll never mention
it all just all of a sudden you
mentioned it
you already meant uh and this is life
isn't it the cat all right so there's
gonna be a an inner circle of people who
understand what I'm doing but everyone
else would be like does he know what he
looks like
I'll just never mention it yeah I got a
beard and they're like no no but you you
you have a goatee and you're like a
mustache and I'll be like yeah you know
what's fast I've always looked like this
when I was young goatee was in people
were all walking around with goatees and
it was just like normal go tease I'm
like remember Starbucks was really new
and like sushi was this new thing in the
Midwest that was around the same time
like men with ponytails and goatee yes I
think that was like so certain like
character the goat that someone who
rocks a goatee is someone who like he's
a drinker he's a partier he's a little
bit of a heck I want to say until now
he's now hoping that all the way I look
side down everyone goes oh I thought you
were smart
I thought you were curious but yet you
have no goatees well the goatee becomes
the smart man's beard maybe I should
grow a goatee no yeah yeah come on this
we're talking about Ethan's career I've
tried I've tried so many times to do
something interesting with my facial
hair when I grow it out by the way I
cannot grow to that length because all I
end up with is pubes
I have pubes on my is it kind of it's an
oily and it's pubie do you shower it
snow is that part of the problem that is
part of the problem any years to figure
that out why am I so oil why do I smell
why is this chicken fermenting in my
beard right oh yeah yeah I notice you
have a piece of corn in your pocket is
that part of the hygiene this is all
part of it yeah it keeps the bad spirits
away right know you provided this yes we
did it is raw corn it is and guys we
discovered raw corn is
good you discovered I already knew this
rock horn I was we were posing for a
picture because Michael has a raw corn
memes actually have a I have here some
photos that I can show you it's usually
cooked corn in my pictures but what we
have no way to know that but this was so
sweet and creamy it absolutely blew my
mind I've never had rock corn before I'm
not gonna bite into it because I know
you guys hate to here meet you
you guys can munch away but I
specifically have a problem I'm allowed
I'll limit my munching but Michael what
is with the corn gags is that a what's
what that what tell me about the genesis
of the corn gags and while you're
explaining yourself because you owe us
an explanation flying yourself nothing
is more funny than joke explained is
that you saying you don't want to
explain it because I will accept that I
feel like it'll ruin the magic you know
so much of it is wait is there a deeper
meaning here all right here's a collage
at the tongue but there's this and so so
much more corn magic
I loved this picture in the upper left
that's that's yeah we shot in my
hometown on the on the football field we
built a neural network out of people and
one of the participants his mom was like
just across the street and she brought a
bunch of corn for me mm-hmm
and it was raw corn because she was
aware of the meme well he was and he
like texted mom bring the horn he's like
I love you I'll do whatever you say and
then boom we corned out together and
that's awesome memories were made well I
you have a so many corn pose let me find
my favorite one if I can if I can choose
it's so hard to decide but my favorite
one if I hop on over your Instagram has
got to be and I know this makes for
entertaining
searching through Instagram but I
thought it was near the top but now I'm
losing I'm losing hope that's my least
favorite that one there with a funny
corn that was taken at a smokehouse in
LA it's a hairy corn Oh what is that
your least favorite I think that one is
it's not a gallery it doesn't have the
same action
you need blurry corn action well I'm
looking like an idiot and I'm not
finding I think you're out already like
literally the first corn pic you've
already passed it's that one on the left
here there okay we're coming back season
two very strong what what sort of
features are you remembering it was a
close-up and maybe it was this one I
think it was this one this is my
favorite corn pic yes it's so blurry
there's so much emotion going on really
almost you can't even make out the face
let it yeah corn and the eye is really
distorted and big yeah but yet everyone
knew yeah well you'll see that you know
what it is corn fascinating why wasn't
there an episode about this and your new
season well the problem is if I say too
much it loses its mystique mm-hmm right
it all began with my father if I can get
deep here for a second he would like
just say weird stuff out of nowhere
sometimes like he'd be in the bathroom
and you just hear like corn dog Willy
was a friend of man and I'm like I don't
know maybe that's a real song I don't
think it is I don't think I don't know
who it is but it kind of became a ear
worm for me like still it gets stuck in
my head like corn dogs and and so then
my wife and I got a cat and I was like
let's call it corn many money and she
like was into it mmm we have a cat named
corn and then I just started to be
consumed by the corn and now I can't
stop do you really like corn stop that's
good a stretch but I'm on the page ie
I've tweeted that pun before so clever
yeah that's one you've thought of and
consider me let me also clarify I I'm a
corn the vegetable I think it's okay I
really support it but is this really the
kind of corn I'm talking about because
corn is also my Catholic amenity sauce
is also a word for small things like
corned beef right oh the corn refers to
a
believe the the salt like the you've put
corn in process according process and
also a band as well and that's what the
K yeah that is completely different
I have not associated with you're not
promoting the you're endorsing corn corn
with a see okay what the K is the band
that you worried or either name you were
endorsing the band corn the band corn
with the seat yeah but you know what to
be look I'm just gonna I'm just gonna go
go into this like I think it's time to
move on I think that the corn thing mmm
I don't want it to become oversaturated
it's time to move on we're hanging up
the corn right now I'm not hanging it up
right now you can't just hang up
something that's taken over your soul
what you can do is evolve so I think a
few days ago I tweeted cat burp huh what
was that about
there was no corn there was there uh I'd
have a cat named corn you see how it
wall uh-huh but I don't know where this
is gonna take me I cannot really explain
I did that tweet perform do you look at
performance and does that it does that
fuel kind of you're intrigued like the
corn thing people were kind of
responding to it probably right and
that's what fueled your curiosity I
wasn't surprised as I was responding to
it hmm if I share my passions the likes
will come it's the genuineness it's
again people respond to the genuineness
so how did cat burp respond for you oh
really well and you know and it's always
this weird mental thing where like I've
been making a lot of videos this year
and they get a certain amount of
attention but then I tweet cat burp and
it gets ten times more interactions
there of course and I'm like well and so
again yeah it's real I'm like hey
everyone support Alzheimer's research
and blah blah blah go to this link and
like five people are like hate you
yeah but then I tweet cat burp and
everyone's like I'm gonna die someday it
becomes this deep meaningful thing and
they love it and I'm glad for that it's
cat burping a thing - cats burp I can't
find a definitive answer okay and just
alright it's not in some of the major
veterinarian textbooks of
shredder burp right have you I don't
know is it a bird off like I think he
actually burped I don't think he's
burped boy they won't lock him out a dog
yeah
they have different digestive yams and
their diets or maybe more similar but
like they must have the ability to burp
I think it can't happen but everything I
found was if your cat is legitimately
burping that's weird it needs something
that is medical attention right a human
burping is just a normal part of how we
work digest I'm not a doctor definitely
on a cat dr. ok do cats burp I got a
feeling we got a new Vsauce video coming
yeah that's true sophisticated but
sometimes we're afraid to acknowledge
that we treat it like it's you know just
oh it's just deep fry just Bubba no it
is the beginning and end of humanity mmm
right that's that's great I mean I just
post pictures of me being fat but do you
Gandhi's that really all it is well I
think so it is shattering the norms I
mean no one I have ever fallen on social
media did that that's true of an
incident image Oh quite rare in cats dan
has done some research here he says
while common in humans thank you for
that burping coming humans burping is
quite rare and cats in fact according to
dr. Anna hosen has yeah right not real
doctor a staff doctor at New York City
Animal Medical Center who specializes in
small animal internal medicine and ok
come on it's uncommon that it even
appears in two major veterinary attacks
she regularly consults I swear I've
heard my cat burp but the lack of
information out there indicates that if
cats do burp it's very important to
their overall health yeah it's not very
important to their overall but that's
the same resource I was reading the
other day and that's not much as it was
so mysterious I had to tweet it so you
see the cat burp didn't come from me
going what's gonna be weird something
deeper being like do they burp or not I
can't believe I can't find out I'm gonna
just tweet it out there get the
conversation started
let's get social in other words let's
break the internet guys conversation
begins there you go
I am vegan mm-hmm how about three days
for three days you've been vegan yeah
that's awesome for three days
today's the third day I'm tired I'm
confused I'm disoriented
I'm scared are you doing it right I mean
not just eating like french fries oh no
I haven't had anything unhealthy yet
yeah no I'm vegan I'm all out and I'm
doing it for health reasons and it's
been three days and I'm still fat so I
don't know if I'm doing anything wrong
look you can be really bad and vegan I
mean I then can get zoom a lot of
calories I think it takes extra work to
be super fat and vegan because you
basically just have to eat like tons of
bread basically french fries I mean that
dairy I'm already noticing in these
three days the cream the cheese the
dairy that [ __ ] I eat so much of that
shape it's in the Seine and that [ __ ] is
just like poison
so do you feel better for not having
that for three days I feel tired
interesting now look this what I always
feel tired
this whole bread and potatoes thing
that'll get can trip you up but you're
in the right City to eat well vegan I
mean you guys know the cafe gratitudes
the but now I can only name one cross
for all the other ones
takis Madre I work with a whole bunch of
vegans so the the Vsauce office
primarily this office to kind of they're
not vegan register I become fully
conscious by the way I went for the diet
and it's been three days and I saw like
ela eating like a sandwich and I was
like excuse me see I was on the sandwich
excuse me it had I don't know some kind
of animal product I said excuse me
ela Meat Is Murder Wow I don't you have
a conscious you know that the conditions
that animals suffer and to produce
animal products there's a holocaust
going on every day in this country
billions of chickens and cows being
murdered every day Meat Is Murder
I'm a vegan for three days how do you
feel how how do
you sleep at night yeah that animal
Nadia had plans for the future ambition
excuse me but I I shake her away every
20 minutes I was vegetarian and Ethan
was the one who because of him I stopped
what I'm been hearing is excuses now to
be fair she's eating for two right okay
the health of the babies fair about that
Nami I I'm I want her to you mean with
the we got a little baby inside her you
don't have to eat meat when you're
pregnant but you know you shouldn't like
eat the wrong things or skip things Yeah
right she'd worry about the baby
I heard about people vegans who forced
they're like animals to be vegan and
obviously like dogs our current current
if carnivores they eat meat and so they
were like killing their dogs and
malnourished sharing their dogs from
giving them a vegan diet
we should fact check this cuz I've heard
Dan fact-check that dogs can't eat vegan
diets I think cats dogs can kind of get
away with the cats definitely can't
catch [ __ ] and I really heard of people
doing that to their cats and that that's
unacceptable doing that to their newborn
babies and they just [ __ ] like kill
their baby talk to a doctor please
yeah I'm vegan so um by the way there's
ongoing debate I always hear people
asking is semen vegan I think it would
certainly be vegan and it is and here's
why
right I've researched a lot of reasons I
know you know a lot you don't need to
research this well just think about it
I've done a lot of extensive research on
and off the field in and out of the lab
yeah now semen is vegan because a human
can consent to give you their camel
product animals cannot consent and so if
you're wondering HeLa yes semen is vegan
is it now I've heard it's not always um
that consent is required because for
instance and animals placenta might be
okay for a vegan because it's abandoned
by the and it's abandoned so you can eat
their [ __ ] you could definitely get out
what I would be there might be however
the question is there might be you know
if they're a carnivorous animal who has
outputted the feces there might be
meet bye-bye you in you didn't make any
choice and because the animal was
existing in its natural habitat well I
almost don't need permission but the
[ __ ] is way so I would say if you're
vegan you can happily feast on an
animal's poop and good clear on that man
yeah I'd and I don't think you're not on
my way the animals wealthy nor any of
its rights by eating its poop so
according to this council we all agree
that you can feast on poop as a v8 but
can you can hold on hold on if I cooked
poop to the right temperature would it
be safe to eat that is a something for
you you two to explore in your next
Vsauce video guess what I already have
explored it as it turns out yeah oh
really
you can cook I mean if you cook it to a
temperature that kills all the organisms
then you know you could eat it
hmm but you don't even need to cook poop
to eat it and be fine if it's your own
poop for real apparently eating your own
union is not that bad other people's
poop don't do it huh you're just putting
the same you know microbes that are
already in yourself so now some what I
should probably walk this back a bit
okay right and I'm sure everyone's gonna
go uh actual like I just ate my own poop
Hospital and so don't eat your own poop
but if you have to eat poop
make sure go with your own and microwave
it first if you can well I'd say like
pan fry with a little you know some
shallots and have you tried little cream
sauce I've never tried it
hold on now I do think that would be
intriguing to cook your own poop and eat
it but it is such a good question it
really gets well part of like why can't
we eat some things and not others what
is poop what is hygiene well you go too
far with our hygiene well I was watching
a really fascinating documentary about
you've probably heard about this poop
transfusions yeah there's really
diseases of the of like a speck terrier
corne you know test test an old bacteria
and people with healthy good gut
bacteria and intestinal bacteria they
suck all the [ __ ] out of the [ __ ] of
the unhealthy person it's it's you can
really want a fecal donation yeah sure I
mean if you want to be
they [ __ ] in another dude's ass holes
really you want to get down to brass
tacks no but they take all that ass out
and then they like pump all the ass end
of a healthy person and it heals is
really rare it completely heals them
it's like a miracle treatment it's
fascinating
yeah right Michael it's fascinating and
it really has improved a lot of people's
lives a poop transplant yeah the poop
they poop they [ __ ] in another dudes
[ __ ] no they're also synthetic poops
that can be put into your body if you
need that infusion of good bacteria it
doesn't have to be another person's
there's even an artist who like a decade
ago created a machine that you would put
like a hamburger in and it had all the
right mechanisms and all the right
chemicals
mm-hmm and it would turn food into robot
made artificial poop could you eat it if
you cooked it and it could eat its own
poop have you really like a bit there's
like a who's on first base can you poop
can you eat the poop or if you cook it
but if it's your own you can eat it
that's the point of every story we're
gonna tell today welcome back to season
2 nothing's changed it's the same season
as it ever was
do you guys edit these down no I know
it's live but do you then put out oh you
put out the whole thing
there's no way not to because on YouTube
it'll be it's like out anyway and we
were on tour alive oh we had opportunity
to edit so now when you stop putting
this out when you stop what's the word
yeah then it's just saved and that's the
episode that's up on your back right
right it's like a tweet it cannot be
edited it is history and it will forever
be encapsulated for all eternity like a
healthy poop in the intestines of a
healthy person but it can be transferred
into another intestines for a healthy
poop that's what happens when you watch
it mm-hmm that many fans
alright Wow we blossom through the first
30 seconds quick Oh Julius so guys we're
gonna throw it over to a quick break do
not go away because we have a lot more
to uncover a lot more to discover a lot
more to learn and to grow together on
this journey of feasting on poop so
we'll see you soon and do not go
anywhere dah
now rings mission is to make your
neighborhood safer you might already
know about their smart video doorbells
and cameras that protect millions of
people everywhere but ring helps you
stay connected to your home anywhere in
the world so there if there's a package
delivered or a surprise visitor you'll
get an alert and be able to see hear and
speak to them all from your phone that's
thanks to the HD video and two-way audio
feature of ring devices now let me tell
you something me Neela we don't live in
the best neighborhood it's not the worst
neighborhood it's not that bad but I
mean like it's a little shady sometimes
at night and I would not feel safe at
home if we did not have these rings I'm
reeling you six of them they are a life
changing now you can get started right
with the doorbell ok so if anyone
approaches the door you get a
notification of motion notification on
your phone you could talk to them it
saves it uploads it to the cloud
nobody's getting away with anything when
you've got rings but we've got them on
the sides of our house on our driveways
you cannot approach our house without us
knowing and the video call it is the
best one and you can talk to them you
say hey I can see you buddy
and then you know then they can talk
back to you I mean this is space-age
technology next year's 2020 the future
is now it came a year early that's what
ring is you got to try it if you're at
all curious now as a listener you also
get a special offer on a ring starter
kit available right now with a video
doorbell and motion activated floodlight
cam we have four of those I freaking
love those the Stargate has everything
you need to start building a ring of
security around your home
so go to ring comm /h 3 that's ring comm
/h 3 to arrive in the future 2021 year
early ring calm /h 3
here guys how about some free money
that's basically what honey is it's a
free check in your pocket
millions of top-rated sellers offer the
exact same product on Amazon finding the
best deals feels like looking for
invisible needle on the best and the
world's biggest haystack but thanks to
honey the free browser extension I
always get the best price on Amazon
without lifting a finger
honey automatically goes to work
whenever I shop on Amazon it compares
the prices of every seller that carries
the item I want honey even factors in
shipping sales tax and Amazon Prime
status to make sure I'm getting the
lowest price possible it shows me the
best deal every time even if Amazon does
it it's like having my very own personal
shopping assistant honestly honey is so
easy to use it feels like cheating it
feels like you're robbing a bank at
gunpoint no that's no it doesn't feel
like that but it's legal so it can feel
like that but it's not it's just a smart
automated deal finder that gets millions
of shoppers the best price on Amazon and
all across the internet now let me tell
you show you guys an example I was doing
a little shopping at coach I got myself
some shoes in a new wallet for Christmas
and it was $400
don't judge me and just I didn't know
where honey swoops in with $25 off
holiday 25 I didn't know about this boom
look at this 25 off that's what it does
for you on Amazon and almost all major
retailers across the internet it's free
to install it just takes a matter of
seconds more than 10 million people are
using honey to save money and they've
got over a hundred thousand five-star
reviews on Google Chrome store
Time magazine forget what Time magazine
says listen to me it's free money we
both said the same thing and I said it
first
so next time you're shopping on Amazon
or anywhere around the web don't wonder
whether you found the best deal just add
honey to get the best price
automatically so add honey for free at
join honeycomb slash h3 that's join
honeycomb slash h3 takes a couple clicks
bam bam bam you're set for life
boy valentine's Day is right around the
corner and rather than spending all that
money going out to fancy restaurants why
not just hang around in your underwear
all night courtesy of me undies me
undies you
is the coveted micro modal fabric which
is three times softer than cotton this
fabric genuinely feels like actual
heaven against your skin and boy is that
soft right ela speaking of prints this
VJs and mandis will be releasing a new
print every tuesday that means that you
and your loved ones could chill and
matching prints for v-day and play the
game of how long can you keep these on
and if you're by yourself how long can
you keep it in
speaking of micro remote oh look at
these beautiful Valentine's Day socks
they're so soft breathable and luxurious
if you're a couple you can put them on
and hang out and just your socks
together and if you're by yourself you
can jerk off into it what if you're by
yourself they're really lame well why
would you buy yourself Valentine's Day
underwear that's kind of the saddest
[ __ ] I ever heard that's a lot of people
you think buying themselves Valentine's
Day underwear oh by feel special tonight
baby lighting candles for yourself that
me yes yes yes but why stop at undies
this year's Mandy's is launching their
v-day prints and lounge pants and
onesies as well both are made from the
same micro modal fabric that is coveted
around the world me undies has a great
offer for my listeners for any
first-time purchase when you order me
undies you get 15% off and free shipping
that's a no-brainer
get 15% off a pair of the most
comfortable underwear you will ever put
on so to get 15% off your first pair of
free shipping and a 100% satisfaction
guaranteed go to me undies comm /h 3
that's Mandy's comm slashing welcome
back everybody I hope your buttholes are
well kept and clumped and clean and
dried back here with the wonderfully not
very family-friendly show I try to be
but what I just said poop oh you hated a
word stop it oh the a word yeah I was
like damn was so but yeah I heard
Michael they first of all happy birthday
your birthday was on Wednesday am i
right that's right
Jen we're here the same age as me 33
years old is that the best applause
sound effect you guys can get
I think it's fine it sounds like we're
really clapping thank you you're 33
years old same age as me have you
noticed the effects of aging because I'm
starting to notice like some things but
tell me what's your experience about
being an old 33 year old I mean I think
physically yeah especially with this big
beard there's like a lot of gray in it
mm-hmm right and I always had a gray
hairs there not a lot but I think
mentally it's really interesting because
I don't know you're kind of reaching
this point where the the things I was
nostalgic for like Rugrats and Doug and
salute your shorts and that and always
set me apart from lame adults but now it
defines me as a lame adult because the
young people now are like oh my gosh um
what's what's a show that's like way not
old now I'm like Carly I car there's all
these Disney shows people knowing that I
Drake and Josh yeah and it's all and
they're like that oh my gosh that was so
long ago and I'm just like yeah what
about David the gnome remember that I
don't like um no and I'm like oh my gosh
this is like when my parents would say
you know Howdy Doody and I'd be like wow
just die already
you know right so you realize that oh my
gosh like I'm just becoming an adult
like there's now I'm me and my peers are
like running the world there there is no
one above us who's like they know what's
going on they're in charge now it's like
we are and it's huge no we're lame we're
lame I don't think you feel like I
didn't make a judgement about yeah I
don't think a judgement was packed I
don't think it's I think it's too early
to say much about Millennials like weird
those lame adults weird some adults are
cool all right I don't want to like I
don't wanna get my adult sponsorship
canceled
I support adults but like watching
history documentaries and you realize
that all these people that are like have
been such a big part of
where we are today and they're all like
our age when they were doing these
things and you're like I'm in that face
I had that similar epiphany where I was
like almost everyone around me now is
younger than me right I'm the old guy
now right and I'm not interact like I'm
so used to being the young guy right
where everyone is older than me around
me and so it's coming to the point where
we're gonna be the old dude right and
lame yeah okay well I'm trying to we're
trying to be a little more optimistic
here yeah why do you microwave some poop
and eat it why are you fear roast if you
mug if you're gonna cook poop and eat it
you might as well microwave it and that
seems soothing it already comes out
quite warm 98 apparently is not enough
warm
iced poop could you get it cold enough
that all the organisms inside die flash
freeze yeah we can't we're trying to get
off this we're gonna get off this so we
blast poop into space and somehow propel
it back in to atmosphere and can you eat
it then I just don't know if I want it
to be exposed to cosmic rays and the
radiation that's for real you think that
would be a danger it could mutate the
bacteria indolent super poop bacteria
and now don't look at sorry another
thing is the I compare things a lot like
when I was a child music from the 50s
was like oldies and it's still called
oldies but in the 80s music from the 50s
was 30 years old now music from the 80s
the 80s is 30 years old so two children
born now music from the 80s is like what
Elvis was to me as a kid and it felt
like Elvis was from this different world
yeah it was so far in the past yeah
that's amazing and it's a little strange
now what about like frequent urinating
that was kind of more what I was asking
you about I I'm urinating the same
amount which is actually a lot I really
love urinating you
knowing I'm like urinating so much more
than I used to I don't worry having to
go and then going and then feeling
relief what about in the middle of the
night no that's fun what is fun about
you should be pregnant
I don't think so I like waking up in the
middle of the night you're all alone and
you know there's a couple of app games I
played you got chest to open up really
you open up your phone when you yeah and
I'm like while I'm peeing on you take it
take it to make a special and I go to
bed and I feel like I've accomplished a
few things so I deserve to sleep again I
try to keep even my eyes closed wow wow
yeah well because a lot of because I
don't want to wake up and once I wake up
it's so hard to go back to bed if it's
the middle of the night and you can [ __ ]
around on your mobile game and then just
be like okay end up I'm not like
focusing I'm just like ah I need to open
that chest and start unlocking that one
what game are you playing
you're embarrassed to say what is it
well I mean I think they should sponsor
me before I start talking out of it made
without but I mean what kind of game I'm
Carrie it's a golf it's a golf game
called
golf clash by play Dimmick is that them
guys who make clash of Clan or people
just you know I dish I literally don't
know it could be that they're the same
company it could be the clash is just
like I don't know clash of golf Michael
do you play golf
I've never played golf I went to a
driving range one time how'd you do I
don't even remember I was like oh seven
yes but but golf on an app no you've got
the ball guide you can be a lot more you
know mathematical about it or it's not
so much like getting into physical shape
it's about mental shape physical shape
is so important though your brain is
part of your physical body you need to
stay in shape but right but when you
play real golf you don't unlock a
platinum chest because you want a ture
game no absolutely not
what would you find in those chests that
would be so valuable to you oh jeez like
I'd really like to finally unlock
Cataclysm right
what is that only the best wood in the
game when it's at a high enough level Oh
see you unlock clubs are you guys also
not obsessed
with this game I don't even know I've
been playing balloons td6 which is one
of these oh that's the [ __ ] right that's
uh I have to I have a little bit of a
bone to pick with this game to be frank
with you it's a tower defense game dan
you've played the number six by what I
don't know if I've played six I am
familiar with the series the series it's
a yeah me too I love it I've been in
love with them since broodwar Starcraft
back in the day we're the same age isn't
that great
when's your birthday June 25 same things
so you're like six months old 24th some
water regardless we've been talking mile
minute I mean there's so much to cover
regardless there's this game you defend
balloons as monkeys with darts okay it's
great it's a great game but here's in
light where I get really frustrated you
have to buy the game I think I paid
$5.00 for the game we need to buy it
just to play just for the game and so
you expect well I'm buying the game so
I'm gonna get a whole game a wholesome
game and but what you end up getting is
you have to still buy a bunch of like
[ __ ] do you join well you're at such
a disadvantage that it's all it's the
unsatisfying display and I'm like dude I
what the hell like this game should be
free at least if you're gonna you know
why golf class really hit thanks and you
go back and bleep the f-bomb it's live
golf clash is a game where you can
definitely pay to get special balls and
extra cards all those clubs exactly but
you know you don't have to I haven't
spent a single dime I don't mind if
people do sure but I kind of like the
challenge of can I just through what you
get without pain and be competitive and
it means I've had to be better I've had
to study more I've got to have all the
spreadsheets and the notes I got a
really like plan out do you really have
spreadsheets and notes or yeah being I
could show you my notes that are in my
bag I gotta have them with me in case I
get like a free minute and I'm like ooh
time to complete the two or opening
rounds are gonna in soon you're being
theatrical Am I yes because they're not
selling well anyway Michael I appreciate
the anecdote
what are you talking about who's not
selling I don't I don't believe a golf
game is gonna be that complicated
they're trying to sell to Moe I mean
there's kids playing golf games you
don't have to crunch numbers you're not
doing Pythagorean theorem and crunching
MC equals MC talk and just push the
button and then probably time it with a
ring um there is some timing
there's also topspin sidespin curl wind
adjustments yeah Joe should I do the
rough bump here do I have enough facts
pinta just go right to the green yeah
that's something that you have to learn
this may ruin a theory meanwhile this is
what the game looks like it looks a lot
like this because you always play
against a real opponent oh that's cool
so you're spending half the time
watching him oh it's my turn and there
we go that's fun okay cool now you try I
will say one of my favorite games of all
time was a golf game it was Tiger Woods
golf and it's so cool because you can
upgrade your guy you get the club's like
you said you get you're all over the
place you're hitting your hitting drives
that real people would only dream of
driving that far and you're feeling the
rush Mario Golf on gameboy color was my
favorite game and so you know a few
months ago I was like there's got to be
another golf game out there that's good
mmm downloaded a bunch don't you stay in
mario kart mario golf Oh Mario go yeah
on gameboy color I played that version
and I loved it and also I I get really
into the whole like ooh if I play a
little bit more I'll have a few more
rewards you know and they get you on
that kind of like I'm making progress
mmm but you can see the results of it
like ooh ooh I know how to play this
shootout mmm I know that you but you you
have to curl a bit more than you might
think and really the way to go is
through the left don't go straight at
the hole that looks easier but watch
this and then your opponent's like oh
and you're like can you talk [ __ ] to the
other person you you can only use the
preset emojis they provide but people
find a way to still be mean with them
they can it really that people always
find a way to really aggravate each
other with those yeah so like when you
[ __ ] up and they say like good game good
game good game good game or something
like that
well got a nice shot there cast nice
shot well played here
good and you're like I just fell in the
bunker me they're both spam emojis when
you're trying to line up a shot when it
really matters you're running out of
time so then I'm the opposite I'm
terrified that people will take what I'm
saying the wrong way so I only say good
game if I've lost interesting if I win
sometimes I feel like they might
interpret it as I'm gloating right so
I'll say something like good luck
but even that kind of sounds like a Liam
they need a little because you're bad
good luck idiot what you do you're sweet
guy man you got to go heart of gold I
don't want anyone to like discover my
account or a kiss epic involve
questioning me like this guy's Michael's
a jerk because people love those stories
I'm like who's actually really what
that'd be great if there was an expose
on Michael from his golf talking yeah
now Michael season three has just come
out yeah all the episode all eight
episodes are up available to view
YouTube red they don't call it YouTube
red anymore they call it YouTube premium
you can help me not what happened they
just love rebranding things because it's
confusing right they want to be
confusing as possible it's apparently
edit strategy right but yeah YouTube
premium is what it's called now I just
focus on its mind field right and who
knows what'll happen in the in the far
future but it's been it's been an
awesome ride and season three is my
favorite season cuz as I've become more
confident like working with a larger
team with like you know deadlines and a
bigger budget and a lot more on the line
I've gotten better and I've also gotten
more confident and kind of being a big
part of the process and the team this
year really understood what made
minefield great we've got an expert from
a university or a research team in
everything they're always there so you
don't just feel like it's you know this
unqualified guy Michael being like a is
this a reality show you feel like oh I
can see how pilot studies are made how
you develop an experiment and how you
kind of try out variables to make sure
that you're ready when you actually
start mmm so well there was two episodes
that stood up to me the first one was
the chimpanzee one that was like freakin
phenomenal that was a see such dude
you guys this one's free so like this
episode was so amazing
you went out to China Japan or Japan
yeah whoa whoa you went up to Japan and
you hooked up with this Reacher's
researcher who studies chimpanzees and
there's this huge natural habitat yeah
were they the chimpanzees come in on
their own exactly that is crazy so right
like this huge open and KL encampment
yeah yeah so I went knowing that other
people had talked about his research
obviously has been published for you
know more than a decade but I didn't
know as much about how he runs the
experiment it's not like all right you
know get the tasers out and wrangle the
chimps into the rooms they've got these
treetop laboratories so - the chimp it
feels like they're just foraging and
instead of reaching out and grabbing a
berry and eating it they reach out and
they touch numerals in order and then
they get the same type of food they
would normally forage same amount and
then that's all calculated so that
they're there the meals that they're
given by the the keepers all add up to
the right amount of food in a day mmm so
they get their whole day's food from
these experiments no they don't
oh they don't even have to go and do the
experiment they don't want to right if
they don't then they'll just be fed a
little bit more later right but there's
even facial recognition cameras that
that can tell which chimpanzee is walked
in so they know what difficulty to give
they know who's eating the food they
don't get over fed and it's just
wonderful now that also made it hard to
film because that you can't just be like
all right bring in the chimps they're
like we have to wait we don't know who's
gonna come it could be one of the
geniuses that's gonna be amazing or it
could be one of the Dumbo's it was
really well shot thank you I did none of
the shooting it was fascinated because
in Japan
do you fly with a crew yeah we flew with
the with a smaller crew and then we had
people there in Japan fixers and and
locals who could help us you know
navigate faster how did you even set up
with this guy I was curious
you know what really helped is seasons 1
& 2 we can say look we're really
interested we reach out to like Kyoto
University's you know Press Group and we
say hey this is the show and they watch
and they go oh yeah this is like not
sensationalizing they're really honestly
kind of like promoting what's happening
and please come out well the experiment
was about memory yeah and so these
chimpanzees was mind blowing they have a
almost what seems to be slightly some of
them have to have like a picture-perfect
memory where all these numbers will
flash quickly on the screen and all
these different grids and the monkeys
can do it all or the chimpanzees can do
it all and and remember it immediately
yeah whereas you competed at one point
against one of these chimpanzees and ah
and I mean obviously you didn't have to
- no but like we are just on such a
lower level in terms of memory yeah our
our memory is so much less photographic
now I was at a huge disadvantage in that
I'd never done it before
if I did it every single day for years I
would get really good but they found
that a human just cannot reach the same
average ability that a chimpanzee can we
just need a little bit longer I think
we're we're thinking about it a little
bit too much the chimpanzee is just
going I need to react to what's given to
me whereas we're going oh shapes and
thoughts and primarily though they found
that it could be language that theory
that the fact that we can talk that we
have language is what makes our memories
so bad is controversial in some circles
but I don't need to have a perfectly
photographic memory if I can tell
stories to remember things right if you
asked me what did you have for lunch I
don't have to go pick the picture out I
can go well let's see it's Jake's
birthday he likes tile we had Taco Bell
we had a pineapple cake because he loves
pineapples but it wasn't banana flavored
and I'm telling a story even if I didn't
have language even if I didn't speak
my brain might still remember in that
sort of way not with English words but
with grammar whereas the chimpanzee is
just in that moment now so this is the
theory of the cognitive trade-off that
in order to develop language we trade it
off memory I mean there's only so much
space in your brain for stuff but what I
thought about is I don't know if you've
seen this there's this very very rare
condition called superior
autobiographical memory familiar with
that yeah this is so I watched this 60
minutes report there's only 10 people so
far in the world discovered with this
ability and they have this ability to
recall any moment any day every single
thing that's happened in their life with
perfect recall yeah I've heard of it but
I don't know enough about it so I'm a
little skeptical air-five yeah well let
me show you a clip can they test they
don't kind of test so this was a 60
minutes report they remember exactly
like on a certain date what day of the
week it was
how old they were what they were doing
like if a current event happened
tested and proved to have superior
autobiographical memory October 1st a
total recall of every day of their lives
extremely impressive Delta Airlines
flight 191 crashes near Dallas Texas oh
I know exactly when that happened
because it was August the 2nd of 1985 it
was a Friday such a gift has never been
documented before and scientists like
Professor James McCord are excited about
where it may lead one of them said it's
like a Google search that you put it in
and and it just sort of there it is
and it it's the huge Minister month and
it's a day and it sort of narrows in and
it goes bang and they've got it and this
all happens very quickly it just
actually I have another timestamp where
they conducting some kind of experiment
this is kind of blowing my mind I one of
my best friends Mary Lou
as this for really I mean I didn't know
what it was called but yeah he has like
this ridiculous ability to recall like
down to the hour of the day events so
you want to get in touch with these
they've only found 10 people in the
world really yeah it's genuinely blowing
my mind because my buddy I've known him
for years and we always just chalked him
up to being kind of a weirdo for having
disability but yeah that's that's
actually kind of crazy here Oh hoping
this is the right time stamp for others
like Jewel Price who was the first
person to be diagnosed with this
remarkable condition it's a burden is it
driving you crazy on the inside yeah
sometimes it does yeah I mean I really
just want to be screaming at the top of
my lungs most of the time and I can't do
that so I have to keep everything in
check when did you realize you had this
ability about five weeks after I turned
14 and I don't really know why on this
day exactly
February 5th 1980 but from that day
until now it's every day and so you know
you pull a jet out boom it's like I'm
right there every moment of every day
ever
I have nothing to add yeah I want to
show there's just one part I want to
show you where they recur where they say
specific days got it yeah that's very
telling yeah
don't believe it well let's do it it
reads out Android January 28 1986 days
old that that anniversary of the week
was it she just said it was a Wednesday
you were five days old I was five days
old and probably not murmuring it maybe
was a Tuesday but it's also my
grandmother's birthday the 28th of
January so there's a lot intersecting
there a lot of reasons why I would
remember the Challenger disaster right I
guess it's a lot of v6 and the Super
Bowl was the Sunday before John Lennon's
assassination that was December 8th 1980
do you remember what day of the week it
was Monday I was in tenth grade it blows
my mind that you can remember that
that crash killed 274 people
the Chicago plane crash the one in May
25th 1979 that is the one yeah I was in
the 8th grade I had just come back that
week from having the chickenpox
remembering historical events is one
thing but these scars a whole lot
further what may 8th my grandmother had
imagine having instant recall of what
you ate for breakfast exactly 20 years
ago today what if I flip it around I
don't give you an Advent but a date
the 28th of February 97 that was a
Friday and I was leaving that day to go
up to San Francisco we sort of got
sidetracked by a bank robbery in North
Hollywood
she's right they have it so there seems
to be some people that have both brains
yep
and one side both it's I don't know a
lot about it but you can see how much
how important it would be to learn like
first of all like knowing the dates of a
John Lennon's assassination and plane
crashes
there are plenty people who know all of
those but imagine being burdened in that
way mm-hmm by every detail being there
it almost makes you feel less bad about
how the past in your memories keep
fading away I only live in a kind of
clear but I I wonder if that's some kind
of defense mechanism you know because it
is a like this little one lady that they
interviewed and this was like I love
having this ability right as you can
imagine the utility of that is insane
I mean yeah you'd be able to excel at
anything like way more yeah level yeah
but this lady says that it's a bird it's
a I could see are you both yeah I can
see it and I don't know what they've
found since I you know what's going on
yeah what are the limits of this and
what might be the cause and what are
some of the the bad side effects yeah
but you can also see how difficult
psychology is if you do physics and you
want to talk about like the mass of a
proton they all have the same mass
mm-hmm but memory all of our memories
are different when you think of being
five what is it like do you see through
your eyes do you see yourself from
outside it's a what is it what's the
fidelity of it is it like a visit like
4k is it like 1080 we still don't really
know and and everyone might be so
different it might be really hard to pin
it down
mm-hm mathematics and physics it's kind
of like look the speed of light is what
it is we've literally defined it to be
something but what is happiness yeah I
would like to get her in there to
challenge that chimpanzee do you think
she would win that is maybe a different
skill different one though cuz that's a
day yeah that's a very different way I
think she would win she's got that we
gotta get her out there to Japan she has
amazing episodic memory she remembers
episodes from her life she doesn't have
that photographic
like instant a scene we got but there
are people who do there are people who
can look at a deck of cards all laid out
and then and then it's called an eidetic
memory because it's not quite like a
photograph if you if you show them 52
cards laid out in order and then you
tell them like what card was in the
corner which one was here they'll
they'll know but if you tell them which
card had a tiny black dot somewhere they
won't remember if they didn't commit
that to memory it's not like they are
pulling up a photo they tore and they
can look for details that they didn't
see or or attend to at first mmm so it's
not quite a photographic memory they
call it eidetic no so I mean what was
your kind of takeaway from that whole
experience in Japan I mean how long were
you there how long did it take to shoot
that we were there well we were there
for like two weeks because we also did
the episode on recording your dreams
mm-hmm
that was done in a different part of
Japan but it was all underneath Kyoto
University right and so we were we were
at the primate research institute for
like four or five days and every morning
we had to get there for like the chimps
breakfast because that's when the two
really famous ones might come in and we
had to do like four morning's just to
capture like oh my gosh you know I has
come what time are we talking about I
think it was like you know 7:30 a.m. but
you're already so jet-lagged you're not
like that's not it's not early you just
we were on a very early to get up and
early you go to bed skit now were these
chimp these superstar chimps were they
was it the result of just like good good
genetics or were these the monkeys the
chimps that were there practicing all
the time well they have trained for a
long time because imagine like they
don't just come out of the trees and go
oh I can do that yeah they have to learn
what numerals are they have to learn how
a touchscreen works it takes a long time
so but there's nothing special about
them otherwise it's not like we found
some chimps that can do this well you
know there's a varying level of
intelligence among humans I wonder how's
that variance among Jim I'm sure and
there's also variation by age you know
as they get older there's cognitive
decline and so I who was
born in the seventies she's now getting
slower and that's who I went up against
so I had a bit of an advantage but it's
not it's not that these chimpanzees were
like you know way above norm they're
they're what a chimpanzee can do and we
used to be able to do the theory the
hypothesis is that as as we split from
chimpanzees through evolution we needed
language to survive we didn't have the
safety of the trees we need to be able
to say you watch out while I get those
scavenged remains and you have to trust
that I will give some to you I'm near it
you're having to do look out or you're
having to do something else
mm-hmm but we have to communicate
because we can't just be safe in the
trees and grab berries all day all right
but you can't develop language like you
can't just go all right guys let's just
build a new lobe on our brain instead
you have to take the cells and the
structures already there and sacrifice
some of them to you're doing language
now right and the hypothesis is that we
gave away some of that eidetic memory
some of that short-term memory ability a
good trade-off evolutionarily probably a
probably yeah probably but I don't want
to judge but who know doesn't mean it
like we're better than chimps it just
means we're different we were forced to
be different to still be here today the
other one the Stanford Prison Experiment
also free also free yeah this I always
confuse with this the original
experiment yeah this original experiment
was very famous this guy set up a guards
and prisoners dynamic and just to still
tell a long story short the guards
became very cruel right yeah
oversimplify it but well I guess well I
I'm confused about what there he was
driving that we are inherently more like
evil or manipulatable or capable of evil
I guess I just didn't really see the
point of the experiment and I've always
doubted this this kind of theory that
humans are born with a capacity of evil
but the Stanford Prison Experiment is
often given as evidence that see at our
root core you just can't help it people
turn bad and the Stanford Prison
Experiment
has been told as a story of it's not
just bad apples it's the bad barrel if
you put anyone in the wrong circumstance
they will behave badly right if you give
people power and you D personalize the
others they have control over and all
these things then they'll just become
bad dude Abu Ghraib oh I mean do you
think that that was proven through their
experiment no yeah I don't I think that
that it is very true that the situation
can have a lot more power than we might
think
but I don't think that it's the simple
story of oh well of course these
terrible things happen because they just
do yeah you know even nice people can go
eat go bad right
that can't happen but I think it's way
more complicated and where the the
people and their own personalities in
the situations overlap and and have
feedback loops with each other it
becomes really gray hmm well the one
detail that actually I learned from
watching this episode I didn't know is
that the researchers where we're
encouraging the guards yeah off the
record to be more cruel right which is
something that they didn't disclose that
part of the story is a rarely told yeah
that's a that's a that modifies the
results a lot yeah there was one guy
apparently who wasn't being cruel enough
and there's a recording of the of the
researchers being like hey dude you're
gonna have to be more you're gonna have
to be more dominating you have to be
more forceful with them otherwise this
experiments not going to work yeah and
urging cruelty in the episode I got to
talk with one of the guards from the
experiment right and he explained that
he thought he was working with the
experimenters he thought the whole point
was we're gonna be cruel and see what
people do we're going to show that
prisons are all bad and need to be
reformed so he thought he knew what the
experiment was about and so he behaved
in a certain way and he was getting
feedback from the research team he
couldn't he knew that the cameras were
recording them and that when he did
creatively cruel things they would like
get a close-up and they'd all go ooh and
so he was encouraged in his mind to be
mean
right so that kind of throws into
question what did we really learn from
the Stanford Prison Experiment I don't
think that the whole thing should be
called a hoax and written off I think
first of all it's incredibly important
as a example of why you need to
ethically study people you can't just be
like let's get some young people and I
don't know give them power over each
other and over the some of the things
the guards did just for people who are
listening who aren't familiar with that
experiment well you know it devolved
into like making the prisoners hump each
other in order to you know get bathroom
breaks it was um
hey you prisoner are going to be you
know locked in this closet until you eat
because some hunger strikes happened and
then yeah I think the guards would come
up with like scenarios like okay if you
all don't choose a person to be punished
then you all lose your blankets so the
prisoners had to go against each other
stuff like that these were all
volunteers so they were paid yeah they
were paid per day yeah a pretty good
amount more than what you would get for
like a just a job the college job you
know at that time but it had to be ended
early because it got so bad now there
was also like a whole nervous breakdown
one of the prisoners had but since then
he said that he was just acting hmm
cuz he just he was wanting to study for
his upcoming tests and they weren't let
he do want to get out cuz I saw it was
this the guy who was like yeah just
started freaking out I mean they were
like okay this guy's like office yeah
he's gone he's gotten out of control but
really he was just doing that cuz he
knew that they would have no choice but
to like get him at it well that's
interesting yeah but I mean I get well
so at any rate you think that this
experiment what does it prove if not
that that humans are capable of not all
humans are I'm not sure what it proves
but it it's a great example in the
textbooks especially of like this is why
we have ethics review boards mmm-hmm you
know this is why we need be careful if
you want to know what's in a proton
smash them together and look at what
comes out you can't take someone's brain
scoop a piece out and be like now it's
different
oh that right in the part
that allows you to answer my questions
shoot you know you have to be really
careful and and there are times in the
history of psychology where that line
has been crossed and we've we've I think
become better but I also think that the
Stanford Prison Experiment
like the Milgram experiment the one with
the electric shocks shows us that people
will do quite cruel things in the name
of something bigger and in Milgram and
in Stanford I think that was scientific
progress hmm they said well this
university is doing this and it must be
important so I don't feel so bad I'm
being told to do this by you know
someone whose work I think is important
mm-hmm so I think that's what we really
learned from the Stanford Prison
Experiment well we still need to do a
lot of work on where that balance is
between what makes someone do evil there
or what makes someone become a hero all
right so you're the experiment you did
in the video or in that episode when
they're in the dark room that was based
on the Milgram well that was that was
our attempt to play around with how
would you run something like the
Stanford Prison Experiment but have
absolutely no demand characteristics
meaning no expectations on the part of
the participants that they were supposed
to behave in any way because everything
we kept hearing was that the
participants in the Prison Experiment
all thought they had to take on this
role oh I'm a prisoner so I guess like
what a prisoners do well they're
obedient or they riot I'll do one of
those too we said what if I don't give
them what we just give them numbers we
don't tell them that we're recording
certain data and we just see if given
the opportunity to hurt someone knowing
that you would never get caught for it
mm-hmm
would you do it and we really struggled
we also cast the most like benevolent
people we're there were all sweethearts
because all we wanted to show is that
there's a point where you just will not
get the results that you saw at the
Stanford Prison Experiment so it's not
an either/or people are either good or
you put them in the rotten barrel and
they all turn into rotten apples I was
wondering were you
wanting to do something more extreme was
there ever a point when YouTube was like
ah let's not do it that way that it was
though it was a weird episode because we
developed that one after season 3
already been approved right and so I was
busy making all the other seven episodes
and still having to come up with well
what's the Stanford Prison thing and the
more we looked into it we talked to a
lot of psychologists and they were all
like you know if you do it today it's
just a reality show the BBC did a
fantastic version that was much more
rigorous and they were looking at sort
of group cohesion and it was very cool
but you know they had a huge facility
and they had a lot of time it's all they
did you know we were only able to spend
an eighth of our time and resources on
this right because we had seven other
episodes so you know I think when you
say Stanford Prison Experiment people
get a little scared and they think it's
gonna go too far so we were even
proposing stuff like there's this really
fantastic experiment involving hot sauce
mmm and and you you as a participant
have to measure out an amount of hot
sauce - for someone else to drink hmm
and YouTube was like too far and I was
like yeah but I mean we've electrically
shocked people in previous seasons and
hot sauce there's like a popular show on
you yeah of all people do you know and
they think they were just so scared that
Stanford Prison Experiment
that's it was gonna violate ethical
rules that we the the hot sauce could
not be hotter than Tabasco stuff like
that Rome like I had a feeling that they
that they had their hands in the but I
appreciate some of those challenges
because it forced us to be better and to
be like you know what maybe we don't
need maybe the punishing can be
something that's not quite so cartoony
but the hot sauce has actually worked in
like serious studies so we used the
noise and I think it was almost more
insidious because we were able to say
we've played it off like we didn't
really know how loud it was or what was
safe we just said anything below a seven
should be safe your meaning
should be safe so if you crank that dial
up secretly it's like a you could be
really hurting someone right but no one
would know that it was you who did it
will people be that cruel and in the end
they were not really were they no they
only ever responded in kind
it was I'm surprised by that never they
never cranked it up you could easily
find people who would sure but it's not
quite as easy as anyone you want into a
room yeah yeah yeah now Michael are you
a tits or an ass man in the end because
we did never get an answer on that I
asked myself that every day
really and did you ever find resolve
within your soul on that issue yeah
which is the answer you're a corner
coordinated how can you not love that I
think I'm personally it's a tough call
between tits and ass but I respect the
that you dodged it and so I won't press
you much much harder on that did i dodge
it or horn is not aid is unless you're
rubbing your dick on that corn later
you're thinking too small
oh that's I see you so you liked it well
corn for me when I see you eat corn
reminds me more of like are you saying
that you like vagina the best because
eating you're like eating corn dude raw
corn
yeah like when cuz when you eat corn it
is kind of like the coital we're not
quite oh what's it called what's the
technical name when a man eats out of a
woman yeah kind of lingo
it's quite kind of really what you're
talking about I'm just trying to eat my
raw piece of corn
he's a vagina man I want to go to
questions from the fans we've got some
great ones yeah sure but guys if you've
got YouTube bred or not get it head on
over to vsauce channel watch mine field
season 3 is therefore in the works is 3
the final season mm-hmm I creamy and and
uh dan has correct premium YouTube
premium sorry I can't say too much I
can't say too much but you know what
there's a lot of really awesome things
on the horizon a lot of opportunity
I'm making choking on corn right here
let me just take a little sip people
here in this analogy that I've painted
Ethan you're really trying to connect
some things here and I'm really glad you
are but corn has has gained a new depth
unless that's what you originally meant
but you know minefield season for like
it all comes back to that doesn't it yes
um I've been doing I've been doing a
video every single week on the dong
Channel yeah Vsauce one will get a lot
of fresh free videos this year I'm very
excited I bit off way more than I could
chew last year and I remember it was
literally December of last year
wait that's not very long ago December
of 2010 I was working on an episode
about torques and rotation and it became
the leaning tower of liar that I put on
dogs I didn't really have time to like
make it as as kind of like complete as I
wanted mm-hm
and I needed to promote brain candy in
Australia and then I realized how little
I knew about physics and classical
mechanics and I and calculus and I was
like I need to get back to basics and I
need to learn a lot so I have been
reading oh and learning that's I think
I've become a better person and it's why
I'm grateful that people are patient
absolutely in the meantime I've done
more videos than I ever have dong is out
there
yeah one should be quite cute name oh
great cool well Michael you're one of
the hardest working people on YouTube
you are out there shaking your dick and
people you don't they're not on the
court are in corn boy
Pam lucky lady we cook it first no your
wife is a lucky lady dude I'm a lucky
man
but the way you chomp corn I'm gonna
stop chewing on corn during this all
right let's go to the questions gap
please number one on the list we've got
two other aks s if you can do any
experiment in the world without moral
value stopping you what would you do how
would how would it not how would it not
stop me well let's say ethical questions
aside is there an experiment you'd like
to conduct
the ethics would normally stop you from
doing yeah I mean let's say we're able
like drinking hot sauce god forbid right
let's say let's say we're able to create
like artificial minds boy even then I
might think that it should have rights
but let's let's worry about that
question a little bit later I would
really love to watch a human mind grow
in isolation never learn a language
never meet another human there was a
case of that the wolf girl right or
spirit there's some really unfortunate
cases when it's it's I mean it's child
abuse yeah of course and so I mean yeah
they're even ancient experiments where
they were like oh we took these newborn
babies and put them in a room and never
did anything because we wanted to see
what language they would speak what is
the like the true first language of
humans and you know everyone's like oh
it was Greek it was Hebrew or whatever
but obviously they never learned
language right obviously yeah but their
brains were still you know wired for
grammar for thinking in the way that
language works but we don't know a lot
because it's really hard to develop
experiments on it so I would love to get
artificial muscle great answer maybe
minds that run it faster speed so we can
really see like seven years of learning
in a day but but that still raises
problems like look if you've got an
artificial mind it's that close to a
human mind it don't unplug it because
yeah it's gonna have dreams and
ambitions and hopes and fears yeah now I
now in the case of these children who
are like raised in captivity are their
brain development is stunted by never
having learned language I wonder
I honestly don't know enough I know that
it's incredibly detrimental oh yeah our
brains are sponges and learn and it's
hard to learn language if you don't
learn it within the right period of time
when you're younger the most famous case
is genie and last I heard I think she is
still alive
she's very old she's um a ward of the
state of California
no one can find her or interview her but
yes she was raised like locked in an
attic and never learned to speak I think
she is capable of some things now mm but
yeah that's when we really realize like
how do you even frame your thoughts when
you don't have language right well you
can it's not like people who don't speak
don't think right well who don't have
any language because you can have people
who have sign language or people who
communicate in ways yeah if you're grown
in isolation you didn't communicate with
people would you do how would you yeah
how do you form thought you know I act
for inner dialogue actually asked
Terrence deacon at Berkeley this that
very question mm-hmm for the chimpanzee
episode and it turned into a bonus clip
and I literally cannot remember what his
answer was
he may have said I don't wanna put words
in his mouth but he he I think hazarded
a guess about what is it like are you
conscious if you don't have language
like are they were like in our dialogue
I think remember there's a great book
called things I believe but cannot prove
and it's just tiny short little like
paragraph answers written by some really
smart people and I believe one of them I
could be misremembering but one of them
was like I believe that you need
language to be conscious mmm and it and
I was like jeez it's full of crazy
things like I look I'm like the director
of this big Institute and I can't prove
this but here's my personal belief
that's great that's cool
thought-provoking
yeah you know what I love I would love
to clone human beings I want to take a
dude yeah clone them five times just
much like the movie duplicity or
whatever was called with Michael Keaton
do they get Dumber every time are they
how much like the original are they
these are in fascinating questions I
want to make duplicity multiplicity
thank you Dan in real life the problem
is that when you clone a person awesome
now you have a little like cell and
it'll become whatever the plasti cyst
and fetus and whatever it
it doesn't come out of a machine
fully-grown yeah I'd like at the age of
30 or something right baby did it has
the same DNA as the adult what happens
if you raise yourself though like
wouldn't that be wild but you're not new
you said yourself you're raising is
totally dis asked you mean right with
the same ma what do we do but so much is
not from we gotta cook we have to
circumvent that somehow that would be a
great experiment on environmental verse
verse nurture though create the exact
same literally army same person put the
same fingerprints for instance don't
come from your DNA identical twins have
the same DNA but different fingerprints
because these just form through random
motions in the womb so I've even heard I
think I've heard this from Adam Savage
who has twins
he was like identical twins raised
together are more different than
identical twins separated at Birth mmm
because of that pressure to be different
right if you don't have someone to be
different from you just follow your
nature more this is all hypothetical
it's the other thing we don't have a lot
of data on is like what is it like when
twins are separated at birth because we
just don't do that
mmm ever since mine field began I've
been like find me twins separated at
birth and our teams have looked at you
know adoption agencies and they've gone
and looked at other countries where
there's a little bit less paperwork done
on in the week this happens more often
and we have not found there's not later
II though every clue came out in like
well now now it's been done I don't know
if this is like a true but or this is
some fantastical like thing but I swear
to god I've seen a show about this then
an identical twin separated at Birth
ended up marrying the same identical
twins separately so two dudes separate
at Birth ended up marrying identical
twins separately right Michael I feel
like you know the real story I don't
know the real story but I've heard so
many of these Leah ripley's believe it
but I've seen it twins separated at
birth never knew each other existed and
then they both have dogs named Bob and
they both work as plumbers and they both
married
women named Amy and they you know I
don't know how much of that is true the
Minnesota Twins study is the only one I
can think of that's like a really
classic rigorous but a lot of work is
still being done it's just hard to find
twins separated at bran next up we've
got what is your favorite unsolved
scientific question / phenomenon by
buttholes with a Z at the end Oh dr.
buttholes yes
he's always got the greatest question
yeah my favorite unsolved unsolved or
unsolvable whatever you like I mean I'm
really I love fundamentals so I'm
thinking the the the the multiverse
theory how can we develop an experiment
or can we to really test how big our
universe is if it's infinite and extent
then because there's only a finite
number of quantum states you can have in
a certain region it's been calculated
that like a googolplex light-years away
just odds are there's another you hmm
because if we have if matter is all kind
of the same everywhere then you know we
only live in this observable universe
that is its size depends on how fast
light has traveled to us but if there's
there's no edge - as long as there's a
wall there's just more so we can't see
it we can't observe it it can't affect
us it's always growing but I guess what
I'm trying to get at here is I heard in
max tegmark some mathematical universe
book just recently the idea that the
laws of physics themselves could be
different right because space itself can
have maybe different states just like
water can be ice and liquid and gas
there could be other parts of the
universe like all of it not just the
part we can see where space is different
where it's permeability to
electromagnetic radiation is different
and light it operates I don't know but
the constants the the concepts of
conservation of momentum like these
could literally be different and we
could try to replicate
that if we had enough energy here but
basically it sounds very sci-fi but I'm
just troubled by the fact that it's like
yep yep light travels at that speed and
oh my god but well what I've heard about
that is like multiverses like different
universes could have different
properties but you're saying it's
possible the same universe we have to
define universe so universally early
hustle reality every thought University
of everything yeah okay so then what
would you call a parallel different
space to like what we occupy I guess
with different properties of matter
right so I forget how what the diameter
of our observable universe is it's
billions of light years right and it
keeps getting bigger as light from
further back reaches us finally but like
way over here there's another you know
so it's of the circle region that could
also have you know galaxies and earth
and but there are there there different
levels of multiverse like level-1
level-2 these are different theories and
one theory allows for the possibility
for the laws of physics themselves to be
different from one to the other mm-hmm
and this leads to the whole question of
like well of course the laws of physics
are what they are because lead the ones
we have are conductive to things
existing like us that can ask why they
exist right but in a universe where I
don't know energy isn't conserved the
same way or something you might just not
be able to get complex life forms that
can ever go
now what's this energy thing about
mmm-hmm
so experimenting discovering what's
going on with all traveling faster than
right yeah I'd also like to do would you
if you could go on a one trip journey
around the universe yes Peter light
would you do it because if you travel
the known universe at the speed of light
I remember Carl Sagan saying something
like it would take you like 50 years but
by the time you got back to earth like a
billion years would have passed or
something would you take that spaceship
right uh well as I get older I feel less
like I would yeah because I'm not as
alone I've got a wife yeah
want to have kids but I was like totally
single I'd be like now come back in ten
years of my time to an earth that's a
million years older yes
I'll be a celebrity but now I'm like I
kind of need to be here for the people
in my life and now by the time you get
back they may have already been like
dude we already our science is crazy we
already figured all this [ __ ] out there
there's a name for that problem we're
like I could get start on my journey and
like two seconds in people show up there
or five thousand and they're like hey
man like we're already like way ahead of
you yeah your whole trip that's mine
yeah what's the point - it's like you
come back you know I mean what could
really did it to you
right you're probably I goes to a lot of
cosmic rays and radiation yeah
you you were a living piece of history
yeah you'll come back and they'll be
like ah do you remember this band the
beats list and you're like it's
pronounced Beatles and they're like we
never knew because no recordings exist
and you're able to like Br imagine if we
had an ancient Egyptian it could be like
here's how we built them like I was
there here's what my day-to-day life was
here's and here's what my cognitive
processes are like here's how I think
and feel and how I described that we'd
be like wow dude but we'll probably be
able to upload brains for like in the
next hundred years and that whole trip
will be like way more difficult to make
when we can do that we can just you know
build a copy of my brain and I don't die
I'm this consciousness that lives in a
comedian near old Adam signing up for
sculpture what is why I'm here let me
say this on that topic I would not
choose to live forever as a 3d printed
neural connectome I don't want to be 3d
printed I just want to be in the cloud
st. yeah fine yeah cloud yeah I want to
die you do I think it's important for me
to be like all right I'm done mm-hmm not
soon yeah but it's time for its yeah
it's time for someone else to be the
adults
I want to be in the cloud that's fine
that's per want to be in the cloud
eating burgers and not getting fat
forever it's very personal but see if
you're in the cloud you kind of already
moved on it's like the not abuse dude in
the matrix I there's a scene that guy
he's eating the steak he's like I know
the steaks real just put me back in the
matrix cuz the steak is delicious yeah
that's me it doesn't have to be a real
state I identified more with him than
Neil I wasn't putting me back maybe the
deliciousness yeah I want a steak it's
real in a way yeah mine I'd kill all my
friends for a steak that's what he did
basically well the vegan yeah that's
true maybe it's getting in my head
what is what this is finally here we've
got what is one question you would want
to be answered in your lifetime oh jeez
oh well easy for me it's are we alone in
the universe yeah this is there okay I
mean just finding well some dope of
what's out there right just finding like
bacteria yeah that clearly did not come
from Earth contamination like it
developed on its own hmm that alone
would that be great change what are the
chances you think that there's a little
something on Mars for us to discover I
think it seems love based on that little
squeak I I think it's gonna be a bit low
to be honest what are the chances that
there's intelligent life out there
unmarked out there I'd say a hundred
percent yeah me too I'm just yeah I'm
convinced will we ever be able to
contact them space is too big I think
zero percent the thing is what like what
is like there's just it's so it's just
such a shame right it's just such a
shame I feel like there's gotta be a way
like a hundred years ago two hundred a
thousand years ago people couldn't
fathom what it's like to be alive today
what it's like to use the internet what
is like the fly what it's like to walk
on the moon I feel like it's just such a
shame that if there is other intelligent
life out there
we're gonna eventually we're gonna shake
their hand and have a hamburger and it's
so limited but we don't know how light
but that's the thing maybe you been
maybe you don't actually have to go the
speed of light maybe you just have to
bend space toss sure sure compress the
space in between us because space can
mean that who did who knows standing
right who knows what the mechanism
there's a thing called like the
Alcubierre drive is just a hypothetical
idea for a spacecraft that curves and
bends and stretches space behind and in
front of it and can travel faster than
light because it's just the space that
it inhabits there if we could do that
then I we've reached a point where we
need to start naming the years
differently mmm you know we say like
bc-ad that's like this big thing that
like separates humanity into two halves
if we develop faster than light travel
or discovered intelligent life and and
like made contact that's another one of
those moments where it's like okay there
was a before and there now there's an
after but also another scenario is like
let's say that humanity can live an
additional ten million years like we go
the long haul yeah we go interplanetary
we can spread so slowly but so
inevitably if we can just get to a new
solar system somehow that's we're going
all the way I mean it's just a matter of
time right yeah and like how close is
the next solar system like a Lightyear
more than that the nearest one that's
like habitable I don't know not even
yeah I mean we don't we don't totally
know but maybe we can hibernate right
hibernate get in there hundred years
maybe you know sure it's nerdi
light-years away 300 I think they're
even closer than that Michael I think
there's one that's like three like in
single digits light-years away we don't
probably know everything but the planets
there but you may as well go might as
well send some [ __ ] hamsters out and
then cuz we're are we already erased
ethics in our hypothetical anyway yeah
we're not concerned about the ethics no
I'd rather send people than Walt's also
robot
a lot of people say robots are gonna be
the ones in they inhabit I know I'm the
Borg but I should the robots get to have
all that but it makes sense because they
don't even need to breathe the goddamn
air you don't need the air they don't
need anything yep a little squirt of oil
presumably yeah I need to get greased up
yeah
what were you guys doing when I got here
everyone was like really greasy oh we
just I don't know why he had this small
Commission oh thank you guys were
kidding cuz Michael came in is like no
one would listen Michael these are a
good bunch of people I resent you
calling them but your smoke machines are
using oil not like whatever liquid or
whatever the what smoke machines what
are we talking about boiling some
upcoming like big vape no we have an old
smoke machine that was just in one of
the bins with blankets and stuff I was
just going through it and found a bunch
of the liquid on everything you got all
Gouda like it spilled out yeah yeah
that'll do it it felt oil e so we said
well yeah that's don't know don't
introduce yourself that way sorry I'm a
crazy right now I'm a mess
hi Jean well unfortunately I think that
most likely computers the robots are
gonna are gonna be the ones to get all
the fun but will they enjoy it no
probably not
and another philosophical question if we
send a bunch of robots out to space and
they end up colonizing the whole Milky
Way do we even how do we even know like
even if they pass the Turing test or
whatever and they're like self-aware how
do we even know that there is anything
inside those tin boxes and you could
just be sending out a bunch of tin boxes
to colonize all of the Milky Way and
they're just acting out of programming
and impulse but truly they're just empty
boxes I could say the same about you
know you cannot how do I know the Box
how do I know that you're not a
philosophical zombie you act like a
human but you have no internal self
awareness or consciousness I'm telling
you this I know listen
robot with
we took a picture of corn together yeah
made of really blurry I told you about
the flavor of the corn did you really
feel that flavor or are lonely horn
taste good and creamy yeah I said I'm
just being really yeah you're already a
robot racing it's safer to just assume
by the way that's gonna be super
insensitive 100 years beep boop boop
boop yeah you're gonna be canceling
everyone connected Michael was such a
[ __ ] back then they will it'll be
robots being like I can't believe this
my theory is doing his robot impression
robot beep boop I have no soul robot wow
wow wow wow oh send me out to outer
space with oil yeah how rude
but in my defense robots now are very
different than robots in the future that
said it's probably safest just always
assume that's something some has
consciousness and a mind like even a
cockroach just you know what I don't
yes he convinced that you don't have a
hope for tomorrow so I'm not gonna kill
you thank you
HeLa doesn't feel that way though you're
just like give me that meat sandwich oh
[Music]
I think the show went off the rails when
we stop talking about poop yeah I didn't
want to say but it definitely happened
it was like was it like the first five
minutes no I was like yeah if you get us
off poop it's just really bad I'm trying
to get there's any other huge things to
talk about
I mean aliens is it really the other one
would be kind of like I would like to
see a fully kind of sustainable like if
we could harness the sun's energy yeah
truly and fully that would be fantastic
we'll get there I don't have any just
imagine having like basically unlimited
free energy yeah I mean that is
something in it a space elevator so we
can get stuff out there as to much less
effort where there
any questions people ask that you were
like I cannot ask him that what's the
worst Quan was and he went one well it's
not that it was I can't ask it would
just seem kind of dumb was why is the
pea stored in the balls no one knows
that was like the number two all we know
is that it is right so what were you
supposed to surprise me today Zack did
you assume what some goose what was it
the giddy up some Kramer stuff you okay
you got me
I don't know what you're talking about I
told Zack our sound lad I said I want
surprised me today
hit me with so uh yeah yeah yeah blow me
out of the water Diddy oh he hit me with
some Kramer's there's one yeah he did
good he tried his best those are never
get old did you just make that noise by
pushing a button no though what all
these buttons do they do and the best
one
I was really enjoying that I always
wanted to be in a Curb Your Enthusiasm
love you want to take a shot what do
these pay what oh wow it's really easy
to know what they are yeah it's like a
toy
it's got gifts listen to this I am a
robot I don't have rights the future
calling dari Michael your scumbag I'm
sorry it's a tension no yeah no that
would you're right it's a it's a song
for our game shows
watch this here watch this thanks for
playing
[Music]
[ __ ] again this is the h3 podcast
did it work down channel no okay hold on
you looking for you looking for
transcendence yeah
wait why does it say ring I think it it
must have been pointed at the wrong I
should be you got a money sound effect
in me with it yeah probably not
but here's a gazebo here you this one
should work or watch the preview so
we've got that on the sound board whose
idea was over there probably
collaborative effort I really want to
push this one
you ready yeah go ahead you're so close
an by a fan of the finer thing I was
look I've been a fan I mean you know I
don't to say that I like made him yeah
but I was so much original content how
could come from one person yeah I know
he's fantastic why why did I start B
sauce so flow yeah inspired me yeah I
was like how can I ever attain I won't
lie this is me when I'm Vsauce Michael
inspired well actually interestingly
that was that when I first found Liza Co
she and we interviewed her for that
video because he stole he was like I
won't lie this is me when I'm driving
you know and it was her videos yeah
unless her video and it went like mega
viral on Facebook I got like 50 million
views man those are the because those
are the good times you know what's at I
don't remember the video that comes
after his intro right what was the it
was just Liza dancing in the car that is
so totally sofala when he's driving
though yeah no totally so you could tell
you can tell he won't lie you can tell
he just like snapped that on his phone
while he was driving like just on the
way to somewhere and threw it up on
Facebook just boom it's so genuine it's
so in the moment it's so candid yeah you
can't build instincts like that born
with
let's send so flow to Mars I think
there's a chance there's something under
there though deep down yeah you know
what let we deep down where it's warm I
think there might be some [ __ ] it'd be
cool if we found proof of some kind of
life and realized oh man life began on
Mars oh when the Sun was I don't know I
think it was or more cooler in the past
I don't know don't quote me on this
stuff but then asteroid hits Mars eject
some stuff makes its way to earth lands
and then comes back to life all of a
sudden now we're here what do you call
that same thing with sperm pan sperm
yeah I just remember me panspermia isn't
that amazing
unlike pan poo Pia which is the correct
way to cook poop and permeate does make
a lot of sense though doesn't is it cut
it's kind of like the macro version of
pollination yeah you know yeah and it
makes it easier to understand how
something that would seem unlikely could
happen we already have a lot of time
universe's old so it's crazy stuff will
happen like self-replicating molecules
DNA whatever but if you allow it to
happen anywhere in the universe and then
it can spread almost like a cancer of
course we're here
almost almost yeah well I'm on a vegan
diet and I'm farting and [ __ ] god
and so I probably should hit the John
I've been having diarrhea since I
started this vegan diet what are you
eating I don't know if you're eating
well well I think I am a lot of lots of
beans so from before I had a I had a
meal a day of eating so putrid it turned
me vegan I had like McDonald's and I ate
it and then I made a pizza in heel
didn't want any and I ate it all and I
was like bro did you have to hit rock
bottom sometimes I did I did I hit rock
bottom and I was like man I want to see
my son turn like 20 at least
yeah so um I said went vegan but I'm
having diarrhea and I feel sick and
tired and scared that's not good you
should feel and confute at or you should
really check out like good vegan
restaurants just want to go to just take
what you normally eat and throw out the
meat in it yeah like really look at I've
been eating like order out Mexican food
almost in almost exclusively is often
vegan
it's definitely vegetarian and delicious
mmm the Indian kitchen all I'm not
afraid to just shout them out they are
the best Indian kitchen yeah they don't
deliver - winner my wife and I live now
so we just have to drive out and get it
oh it's worth the drive where they
located what part of the time you don't
want to say no Maps it okay you don't
know look I'll look it up I was just
curious if it's close to us uh probably
not so well then it okay I thought you
did a little twist I thought you were
gonna say it's probably not close but
what he ended up doing HeLa the saying
is probably not so bad we should end the
show yeah cuz I've got a silver chest I
want to unlock in kitchen is so West
Hollywood
that's uh that's okay we're living in an
apartment right now as we renovate
how are you renovating is it though so
it's not the house I visited you won no
no well congratulations by the way I
think that it's not terrific a huge
though yeah is it at uh would you call
it your dream home I mean my wife's
gonna be living there so yeah oh my gosh
this is definitely me when I bought my
dream home
no we're really happy it's so cute our
first like trip together was to that
same area
oh just like but the point of all of
this was the Indian Kitchen we hope I
would love to be sponsored by like super
local brands not be like hey uh you know
Skillshare calm go and use this code I'd
rather be like you know the Indian
Kitchen 325 Alameda Street they would
get their money's worth they would yeah
you could look like if we were sponsored
by a local restaurant I feel like we
would blow them up people would want to
go eat there you know what I didn't
invent this concept I think the Dana
Carvey show did this like every episode
had a sponsor and it began with like
Mountain Dew Doritos big ones and then
the final episode was like you know mr.
Lee's Chinese restaurants like across
the street from the studio cuz like he
just his ratings were so low the only
sponsor and it was hilarious but I would
love to do that like just shot a thing a
great idea we should add like an extra
sponsor at the end of every one yeah
there's the West Hollywood area and you
need thimbles here's this tiny little
store it's only open on Sundays yeah and
everyone's like wow that is not relevant
to 99.999% of your audience but to the
0.1% they're going love it
all right well I'm gonna go bank a poop
okay drop it off I'm gonna make a nasty
diarrhea do you have but I'm vegan so it
counts for something
great yes guys thank you all for
watching season two is off with a bang
yeah a bang that sounds like this but
Michael first of all thank you so much
for coming my congratulations on all
your continued success in hard work
right back at you
congratulations to both of you obviously
so excited yeah me too
uncle Michael oh sure yeah yeah you
don't have to you can be on you
shouldn't ha ha but you could I cut you
are Uncle Michael now
this minefield season 3 is out right
effing now not on YouTube read that's
not a thing
but on YouTube premium YouTube premium
get yourself ad free YouTube why they
chant what is that what are they doing
because they're you know what they're
doing they stopped making read series
and they're putting on I never liked the
name YouTube sounds like porn so maybe
that's what they're doing finally
changing from the beginning it was so
poorly conceived YouTube red ok great so
now we're going into the YouTube part of
the podcast this is all I guess everyone
knows what's going on it's very doable
just let us how much time we have on the
outro yeah we can we can stop but I'm
curious yeah you're right Ethan they're
putting the original shows in front of
the paywall now yeah because I think
YouTube is realizing you know what what
makes us wait in my opinion what makes
YouTube different from Netflix and Hulu
and Amazon and all that is that anyone
can be there and like really niche
creative people can thrive like someone
who just reviews bathrooms can and get a
big following and so it's earnest as
beautiful but Netflix would never give
them a show but YouTube I think they
think more of like we have relationship
with advertisers we have the biggest
global reach the most eyeballs Netflix
is huge but YouTube has more people
globally right so they're like what's
get advertisers to sponsor original
shows put it in front of the paywall
which is awesome because I want more
people to sign so absolutely it's
awesome that YouTube's premium YouTube
read allowed me to make a show that I'm
really proud of but I would rather more
people see it yeah it couldn't exist
without the paywall
maybe someday at some big-ass hands but
then we got a brand now it's like what
kind of control do they have yeah
because YouTube was pretty good like
self analysis but we crossed that hurl
it was fine but I I don't I want content
that's made for the viewer it's not made
at the behest of the billionaire
corporation I hear you what can I say
I am the most
perfect purse you are a man of people
alright guys thanks for watching next
week do we have a guest next week or we
going balls out we're gonna ball out
next week we may have fouseytube
but maybe that might happen to be
determined nobody's watching anymore
yeah how long do people just watch it
till they're like alright we're at that
point I don't know what it is but we're
there I mean the live viewers numbers
not changed that much yeah we're holding
steady
what do we at like 50 people 15 you
should do find a way to like really see
if anyone can go the marathon with you
like well we would correct that's
awesome I'd love to just have that on I
didn't watch I'm not I don't support you
yeah sure I don't are am i you don't
know you won't know well I don't know if
you watched all eight hours I mean
that'd be insane
I wouldn't be surprised if you flipped
it on for a moment but just to check in
yeah yeah of course
alright let's send this looks a mess
before we get to eight hours all right
so see you next week thanks all for
joining god bless get some corn and get
some corn this raw corn is really
something check it out
really sweet that's a good bite good
yeah alright bye everybody
yeah I'm waiting for you all right
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]